basically what it is it's a problem like
this they give you like a flat sheet
maybe it's a sheet of metal maybe it's a
sheet of cardboard paper etc but what
they tell you is that they're gonna cut
out squares ok have equal size from each
of the four corners ok so what happens
is you start with a flat piece like this
you cut out these corners and then you
fold up the sides so that the box is
opened okay from the top like that now
when you do that what happens is when
you take away X from both sides this
length here becomes 10 minus 2x because
you're taking X off of both sides
sometimes students make the mistake of
just saying 10 minus 1 X it's 10 minus
2x and same thing with this side you're
cutting off X you're cutting off X so
this length here is just going to be 8
minus 2x and then when you fold up these
sides okay you get a height of X so when
you write the volume okay as a function
of X it looks something like this V of X
okay the volume is a function of x
equals ax times 8 minus 2x times 10
minus 2x okay so all it is is the length
times width times the height okay so
whether you want to call this one the
length or this one the length it doesn't
really matter but length times width
times height is the volume of a
rectangular prism or a box but then the
next concept or the next thing we want
to talk about is how big can these
squares be well there's a limit
obviously you can't take a square out
that's so large that it eliminates the
whole rectangle correct so we have to
kind of look so as these squares get
bigger and bigger right can you kind of
see this eventually it's going to
consume you know the entire width or the
entire length of the box so what we can
do is if we look at these quantities
here we know that 8 minus 2x has to be
what has to be greater than zero
otherwise if it's not greater than zero
you're not even taking out a square out
of the corner at all but it has to be
you know it can't be it can't be
negative right so basically let's see if
we can solve this equation so you can
see here if we subtract 8 and we divide
by a negative 2 okay when you divide by
a negative number what happens the
inequality sign changes direction
and you can see that X has to be less
than four okay so that's the idea here
it X has to be less than four if X was
five we'd have 8 minus 10 which is a
negative width and we can't have a
negative value so basically what we're
looking at is if we graph this on the
number line
here's 0 here's 4 X has to be greater
than 0 but less than 4 okay so with me
so far
when you look at the length same thing
this here has to be you know has to be
greater than 0 but also less than 0 so
you can see that the greatest value that
X can take on here is going to be 5 if
it's 6 again you're going to be into the
negative range and we can't take you
know more length than there is available
here so if we took these squares of side
length 5 and 5 that would basically
eliminate the rectangle altogether right
so that means that for this one the X
has to be between 0 and 5 so that's the
restricted domain there okay and then
with the height here you can see that X
has to be greater than 0 okay so if it
was 0 you're not taking a square out of
the corners at all has to be greater
than 0 so what I'm doing here is I'm
plotting these all in the same number
line and you can see where they're
overlapping here is between 0 & 4 that's
the intersection of the 3 sets so that
means that our domain for this problem
is X has to be between 0 & 4 okay so I'm
just using the interval notation not
including 0 not including 4 so the next
thing that we can do is you can either
depending on what class you're in you
can either graph this and if you graph
it it's gonna look something like this
it's going to cross your add 0 it's
going to cross you're at 4 it's gonna
cross you're at 5 the leading
coefficient is positive it's going to
going up to the right okay it's an odd
degree so it's gonna be going the
opposite direction to the left okay so
down here like this but since we're only
looking at this restricted domain from 0
to 4 this is the part of the graph we're
going to zero in on right here if you
want to maximize the volume which is
oftentimes what they they ask in this
type of a problem what you could do is
you could use your calculator to find
this relative maximum this high point
here then you look at the x-coordinate
the point and that tells you
the size of the squares that you need to
cut out to maximize the volume of this
box now if you're in calculus what you
can do is you can take the derivative of
this quantity okay and set the
derivative equal to zero because when
the derivative is equal to zero what
you're doing is you're finding okay
where the slope or the instant radius
I'm sorry excuse me the instantaneous
rate of change is equal to zero okay so
where it's a horizontal line so if you
take the derivative set equal to zero
you can find out where the sex value
lies in between zero and four okay
you're not interested in the one that's
between four and five just the
restricted domain here so this is a
common problem and something to get used
to seeing because you'll see it in all
those different classes I mentioned
before but this is how you set it up
length times width times height you look
at the restricted domain and then you
can analyze the graph over that
restricted domain to find out what's
going to maximize the volume of the box
this right here is V of X and this axis
here is X so again I hope this helped
you understand it subscribe to the
channel check out some other videos on
Mario's math tutor and YouTube channel
and I look forward to helping you in the
future videos I'll talk to you soon